[Music]
okay
I'm Jim Sheldon it's February 15 1995
and with warren siemens director of the
MIT Museum and we're going to talk today
about Harold Edgerton one of mi t--'s
most famous folks so I just sort of like
I thought it was important that we sort
of we get some we get some of the
history down you know that so that it
doesn't sort of go by the boards and
you're someone who knew doc very well
was connected with him over what the
last 40 years of his life know thirty
years thirty years of his life so I want
you to tell us a little bit about that I
guess I first met doc very shortly after
I came to MIT because I was in personnel
and personnel offices at MIT at those
days were in the basement right under
where he where his lab wasn't he just
moved to building for what we think of
as strobe a light he'd moved there just
shortly before and I always had an
interest in sort of exploring and
electro engineering was one of the
departments that I worked closely with
so I got through Stroh badly and I met
him like almost everybody else did in
those days by simply walking down strobe
alley and there he was he'd come out and
say hello or you'd see him and you know
that that not only ultra a friendship
but sincere friendship that he managed
to exude with anybody he came in touch
whether he'd ever see you again or
whether he'd never seen you before you
were his friend we actually worked in
trying to find I was in personnel trying
to find some sort of technician for some
short-term program that he was in I
don't recall much about that but shortly
thereafter I moved to the department
humanities and one of my first things I
remember was doc trying to save the the
birds that were dying because they were
flying into this glass breezeway between
the library building or humanities was
in building two so he'd put these big
cutouts of birds on that disk of hawks
to scare the birds were flying into this
class
thing so Doc's presence was always
always around you you knew he was here
and even in those days he was obviously
he was a mythical character he wasn't
just another professor you knew that he
was somebody that was very important it
might ease history after we started what
is now known as a museum in early in the
summer of 71 and we moved into what
where we are now in this building in 52
in February of 72 when my very first
visitors in this very fledgling program
was doc doc came along because he'd
heard that there was something trying to
save him with his history and doc by
this time obviously was relatively
certain where his place in history
around MIT was going to be but he was
concerned that we were only going to say
paintings and portraits and faces and
that sort of thing and he thought it
might he stood for a lot more than that
we didn't even know what we were saving
at that they were saving anything you
could get and one of the things we had
found early on in this gallery of MIT
campus to find a mighty memorabilia was
an exhibit that doc had worked with was
John Miele a photographic exhibit that
had been taking the late 50s to try and
document the student body at that time
and this was eventually came out in a
little booklet but it was actually a
photographic exhibit that had been done
and he merely gave that to MIT and we
found it there was a terrible condition
but we put it up around are very
makeshift offices and Doc heard about
that and so we probably the second time
he ever came around just poking around
he brought Shawn mealy in with him so we
all hit it off very readily from that
point of view that's at that point said
you know we've got to say the history of
Institute in the histories in the
instrument it's not in this other stuff
so really he was a big supporter of our
operation from the very beginning and I
I would say over the next as we
developed and as I was able to spend
more and more time in this and as I got
to know the Institute better
we could call probably
Oh at least twice a week if doc was
around asking about something rather do
you want this or shall I throw these
photographs out you don't really want
this sort of stuff do you no it
developed into a relationship that was I
was always able to say yes to
it's an unusual relationship because he
was helping us to build our collections
and he spread word far and wide that
about what we were trying to do so he
had the ear to the President to the
upper administration and they were
always there to listen to what doc said
what do you what do you think the you
know right now it hasn't been that many
years since you know since doc passed
away but what do you think the long-term
legacy of Edgerton is going to be to to
the Institute well I think doc
personifies what was traditionally the
mi t--'s way of teaching people of the
way that MIT thought people learned best
I think
doc personified that when he came here
in 1926 I guess it was the the learned
by doing the hands-on method all of
these things I think doc
not only personified that but then went
on to develop but by his own personality
pulling people in I think if anything
over Doc's period of time and that
probably was things that weren't
particularly happy to in Doc's career
here was that MIT moved very far away
from that with the infection computers
and in one sense and so forth and with
various people who wanted much more of a
theoretical Institute MIT moved away
from the hands-on thing and Doc ended up
toward the end of his life as one of the
really last outpost of where a person a
student could go and actually do
something with his hands his or her
hands at the end I think Doc's legacy is
to really show the importance of that
and what Kim Vandiver and the whole
Edgerton Center now is doing is pulling
that back in I mean now it's an ongoing
thing and there's a lot of other people
like like Steinberg
and well I can with can't think of the
name right at this point but that are to
really see this important and are
pulling people back in teaching people
students MIT students that there's
something beyond theory but there's some
you need to as for example and talk to
use this example himself that in his age
and certainly my age the average kid
that came to MIT would have have known
how to take his male or his 49 Ford
apart and repair it
well the in the last few years you just
don't take most cars apart today and get
them back to run so the average student
coming in today doesn't have that
hands-on experience so that not only was
the Institute moving away but society
itself was moving away you can't take
your digital alarm clock apart and put
it back together and have it run so doc
I think was very disappointed toward
this and did everything he could to keep
his course alive bringing in Charlie
Miller and other people to help keep
that thread alive and of course he his
own magnetic attraction throughout
Dokken his darkest days of help could
pull himself back together to give the
most phenomenal lecture that would fill
any auditorium at MIT or wherever else
okay so he by his own personal magnetism
he held this spirit of living by doing
hands-on thing together and now again
now people see the importance of this
thanks to again as I said not just here
at the Institute but really across all
of Education to somebody's I think
that's true to some degree I think I
don't think most of the probably other
technical institutes got as far away
from well Caltech is probably the
example the inception of that but most
the others did not get so as far away
from hands-on education at MIT did for a
long period time and a lot of Doc's
contemporaries I'm thinking particularly
with Jay Stratton Julie Stratton who was
president and exact contemporary of doc
felt very strongly that MIT was moving
much too far away from from the method
you actually need to teach to understand
technology basically you know and and I
think a lot of those people I think what
their their opinion is being upheld very
strongly today by a lot of things not
only editing centers other things are
showing a movement back toward hands-on
what do you what do you think about the
they sort of what kind of influenced
instead of doc when we we try to
describe them oftentimes some people
will say engineer and they'll say
artists and they'll say entrepreneur
then they say inventors and they say
humanists and they say teacher in
depending on sort of who they are the
none of those words come in different
order you mean do you think that that
represents an example of perhaps the
kind of education or the kind of person
someone can be if they sort of come out
of the kind of education at the
Institute said well I think doc was
truly exceptional whenever in every way
along that line I don't think the
average engineer per se has the great
appreciation of what made art and yet
that the doc somehow encompassed I I
can't answer your question specifically
because he certainly was a humanist
because he understood and that's the
that's necessity of the of the human
involvement in teaching he was in that
magnetic attraction made him a good
teacher of course I think the last thing
doc probably would have ever called
himself was an artist yet he was very
proud of the fact that that one of the
negatives that he'd thrown out ended up
at the Museum of Modern Art is you know
hanging on their wall so he wasn't
afraid of that he had a wonderful
artistic eye because a doc and I think
we pointed out this many times if you
look at a lot of Doc's negatives they
don't look very good but doc had that
genius to go focus right into a certain
part of a negative blow that up and get
the phenomenal shot of a golf swing
whatever it might be so he could
understand the artistic merit of
something within something else that
very few people most people would just
print an egg didn't that
but doesn't look very good you know
throw it we throw it away we'll use that
as the print so I think you can almost
every point yes he was an engineer yes
he was the true artist I think in real
sense he was a humanist he was a love to
teach but primarily I think he was that
like that engineering wanting something
worked and making sure that people
understood how it worked and the
importance of making people understand
how it worked so it isn't an easy
question to answer but I think he was
all of those things and a lot more well
as a doc of a fellow Midwestern ER
that's fair to say right or yes that's
what what kind of how do you think that
ever figured in Doc's life in terms of
you know here he was you know as
everyone's always you know always says
around here they know boy from Nebraska
makes good comes to MIT stays the rest
of his life with his wife Esther who is
also from Nebraska what kind of work I
just had reasoned recently to to do a
lot of reflective thinking about it
because this is my mother was Nebraskan
and she was born in the same town five
years to the day of before doc April 6th
1898 doc was born April 6 1903 both in
Fremont Nebraska
my mother has just recently passed away
and I was out in that area talking about
the nostalgia and you think of what
happened over the century that these
people lived approximately the 20th
century how simple life I mean we can't
even imagine how simple life was in
those days in that in Midwest western
part of this country and doc came from
that knowing that life was basically a
very simple thing you you could enhance
it by strobe photography to do it but I
think he always had a great appreciation
for the straightforward simplicity and
he never was a very complicated I mean I
don't think he knew how do we
complicated or obtuse or oblique I mean
he was straight forward and that was his
turn way of doing things his Midwestern
I should say I think based upon that my
mother also happened the teacher I think
that was that that Western way of
looking at things that followed him
through MIT it was to some degree his
charm the straightforwardness this
saying telling what it is but always
having people with you the importance of
that IIIi think that the fact that he
came from that section world gave him
such a different view of what MIT was
that he could he could literally capture
MIT and look at the other people in that
in that period that were also either
Western to Midwestern Jay Stratton came
from from Seattle
Charl stark Draper came from Missouri
you you Jim Killian came from South
Carolina which isn't West but at least
it's a different different atmosphere
and a lot of our people that really well
Compton another contemporary who really
made might even was an Ohioan a lot of
these people came from that part back
here and really saw perhaps appreciate
MIT more for what its potential was than
people who would sort of grown up around
you that's it's pretty hard thesis to
really prove in great depth but in my
thinking is that Doc's power came from
that that personality which was
primarily a simple country boy I mean
although doclet means certainly I mean
you'd be the first to admit I mean doc
was it talk was a great showman oh of
course I mean doc understood his his
country charm induct it up of course at
once he played he played it for all it
was worth simply because he knew it
worked you know but this it was it was
always a simple message it was not a
complicated message he never I mean he
never fooled people he never tried to
work around people he were it was always
a head-on approach and everything
everything I know about him certainly
jiminee you have any good doc stories
that we we got a Kevin before the
records I just wanted we just wanted to
just favorite doc stories that's what
that was sort of the thing we wanted to
close I think one of the my I think most
precious memories of doctors probably
not individual stories about
idiosyncrasies or any of that sort of
stuff there were enough of those but it
was his sheer fortitude and drive and
determination and do what he wanted to
do and it's always been a model for me I
don't succeed nearly as well as Doc was
it was always able to do or nearly
always doc saw one of his students Paul
Gray become president of MIT and this
was in 1980 in the spring of actually in
July of mid July of 1980 doc had a very
severe stroke he was not really expected
to cover to recover from that and he he
had he had overexerted himself himself
carrying stuff from his car back to
under Memorial but Paul Gray's
inauguration was not until September of
that year and Doc announced through
emissaries early on that he was by God
going to march in that parade for his
student and by god he was there to do it
and it was it was it was a wonderful
tribute to Paul Gray but even more so to
doc that he could come from these
literally depths people had not expected
Italy that live after all he was pretty
well along in years
it was almost 80 at that point I suppose
77 and but my god he was going to do it
he's gonna see his person inaugurated
and he did well I mentioned it slightly
before doc had the amazing ability to to
have these very low spells and then when
a group no matter what where that group
was or what that group if they'd invited
him to speak doc would get up for it
literally in up out of bed to do it and
I think gee Mooney is long-term longtime
secretary and assistant really did a
wonderful job of protecting him from
this and when she disappeared from the
scene he had no protection so even at
the end if somebody in Oshkosh Wisconsin
would call and invite him to speak and
he got on the phone he would say yes and
this I think Charlie Wyckoff indicated
the same thing somebody in England who
had gotten him on the phone and said we
come on yeah I'd love to to come but
what I really want to emphasize here is
the the magnetism that he had for the
MIT student body now he hadn't actively
taught any courses for more than 20
years prior to his death and yet every
student knew him every student was a
frequent strobe Ally they all knew him
they all had this postcards and if he
would give a talk on a two days notice
in Kresge which seats 1200 students he'd
have the place jam-packed and have them
entranced no matter what he talked about
he just had that ability do it and I
remember at the dedication of Eden Hall
where he was again had had a bad period
of help and and he wasn't really
actually as I recall expected to come to
that event but nothing in the world
would have kept him away from that
another eye if we go through our files
there's one fascinating thing about doc
that he became interested in time
capsules and every building was built on
the MIT campus from about the mid 40s on
has a time capsule now sometimes he were
coke bottles with with with wax stuck in
it but doc was involved and every one of
those he had a fascination
of of trying to preserve the time that
you're doing something and make it so
that somebody in the distant future
would find that and that the when they
eat G&G branch of or the wing to the
electoral engineering and computer
science building was being completed I
should say when that third part of the
building was being added which was to be
the EG&G building doc of course had to
have a big ceremony to to bury his his
time capsule for that and it was a weird
collection of materials that he put
there now I hope that that building ever
is destroyed so that we have that
material but someday somebody will find
a wonderful collection of material that
doc and there's on the media building
Media Arts Building was being dedicated
doc and this is verified doc would sneak
out at night he and Esther would sneak
out around the edge of the building and
plant time capsules around the edge of
that building and simply because he was
had this fascination with time capsule
and would not could not stand the
thought there was not going to be a
formal time capsule ceremony for that
building lord knows where he got
involved in this and I've never talked
to Esther about it but be well he's when
said you so what do you feel like you
have a responsibility of you said adhere
to take care of the the Edgerton time
capsule these for a while
well I think what we've tried to do
literally from working with doc from the
beginning throughout his life was to
gather just as much of his history as
possible and then with the corporate
legend foundation and other things that
have happened over the last two years I
think not only will his legacy be well
preserved by having all the photographs
in one spot easily accessible to a very
wide audience but such as the seeing the
instruments actually actually used
seeing that so if there'll be a depth
in-depth understanding of his genius
when it came to to figure how to do
something if it didn't work this way you
tried it that way you learned by the
failure you did it so I think what the
museum has literally been
to do with a lot of assistance from a
great lot of number of people is to make
this legacy a very much part of the
available literature about MIT and
that's you can't MIT nitrogen are almost
synonymous both point of view I mean he
personifies what am I the best things of
MIT and MIT is sort of personified the
best thing about MIT are personified in
in editing I mean the two almost
inseparable when it comes to so if you
understand one to some degree you
understand that one to an equal degree
and he will it's it's I think the
average student today is a little who
goes to MIT coming in as a freshman say
today leaves here a little less prepared
to face the world because he he or she
did not know God personally had never
met him they most have heard about him
because of strobe alley and that I hope
will continue I also hope that the
material that we're getting into our
database for this whole project will
enable them sitting in their dorm rooms
working at their own computers to sort
of explore through Doc's fascinating
life and understand more about it I
think just what I know of what we've
been able to see of it thus far they
will be able to do that and I think they
will many students love to explore and
what a better way to explore is in
having your own hacking dig through a
database of Dawkins materials mm-hmm I
think it I think will be heavily used
that way and I think greater
understanding will come about doc and
MIT thanks to it